Jim West desperado Vlada no you don't
want nada Suicide Squad is finally out
and hopefully you've had a chance to see
the movie already because this review is
going to be spoiler filled I've already
done a spoiler free review that's on my
channel right now so this review is
going to have spoilers just another
warning for you let's talk about it my
favorite part of this movie is easily
the first 20 to 30 minutes I like the
set up for a lot of these characters
even though was very exposition heavy I
really really liked the scene with
Deadshot and Batman and his daughter
that was what I talked about as an
integral scene in my spoiler free review
that I didn't want to talk about that
scene was when Deadshot decided not to
try to kill Batman because his daughter
intervened
Batman felt much more like the Batman I
know in the very small scenes he was in
I liked him standing back there like
okay then shoot at me are you listen to
your daughter thank God his voice isn't
like that
I do love Christian Bale though oh my
god I have always loved your hair but
that scene added more to Deadshot's
humanity I really like that scene I also
like when Batman punched Harley just
once underwater that was pretty funny I
was a good laughs one of my biggest
gripes with Deadshot in this movie is
just sort of my own personal opinion but
I wanted him to wear his mask more I
wanted to see more of that mask on him
because I didn't really get to feel
Deadshot as Deadshot it was sort of like
Will Smith as Deadshot because he took
the mask off all the time and the aspect
of the movie that I wanted a lot more of
because I liked it where the flashback
scenes where you learned a little bit
about Harley and Joker and how their
relationship developed those scenes were
almost the movie I wanted just imagine
how cool that movie could be just a
psychological thriller drama with just
the Joker and Harley and watching their
relationship blossom and watching Harley
become corrupted by him that movie I
want to see that movie despite the fact
that I liked most of the characters in
the Suicide Squad and I wanted to see
them in a better movie I didn't feel
they were very well utilized certain
team members like for instance Slipknot
I mean that guy was just like hey fuck
you you suck get out of here
he had like nothing to do in this movie
Captain Boomerang was entertaining as a
presence but I mean there's a scene
where he just takes his boomerang and
throws it into this big thing it just
goes things like well I guess I can't
really do anything here they just didn't
do a good job of explaining why these
people were needed for this threat if
the flash and Wonder Woman exist in this
world and we actually see the flash in
this movie why weren't they sent after
enchantress and Incubus these people who
are just insane with these crazy powers
who are of course shooting a beam up
into the sky and some portal is being
created and they have to blow it up like
why is a crazy woman with a bat who's
good with acrobatics a guy with a
boomerang some guy who can climb
buildings really fast who dies in like
two seconds why are these people the
people who are sent after this thing is
it just simply because they're
expendable the plot that these
characters were given is I think my
biggest problem with this movie these
characters should have been sent like to
another country to deal with some
radical extremists or something like
that which is more so like what the
comics are like not some witch who's
opening a portal in the middle of the
city I mean because in the end it all
comes down to somebody throwing up bomb
into this thing and they shoot it and it
explodes I mean it was basically like
the end of sharknado where they just
throw bombs into all of the tornado
things to make everything explode and
everything's fine after that I guess
also the musical choices in this movie
were very abrasive and didn't really
match with the tone there were a few
times there's like that's cool like
Eminem's guess who's back back again
that worked but then there were other
times where I'm like this song is all
I'm hearing right now and it felt to me
like David Ayer wasn't going to pick
these songs but after Batman V Superman
was criticized for not being fun enough
they just put in all these fun songs
that didn't really match with the
filmmaking to try to make the film more
fun also the line were Will Smith is
like well I was some kind of Suicide
Squad I was like really venom and
spider-man 3 what am i some kind of
venom Peter Parker what am i some kind
of Spider Man Clark Kent with these
powers I am some kind of Superman Bruce
Wayne
in this outfit I kind of look like a
Batman let's talk about Viola Davis I
didn't really mention her that much in
my original review because one of my
biggest issues with her character was a
gigantic spoiler I thought she was a
better adversary than Incubus and
enchantress that woman was scary like
this woman scared me those other two
guys were like whatever who cares this
woman I am scared of Amanda Waller she
was very good in this movie a very good
performance but there's a scene where
she just like murders her associates and
her excuse for this is that they didn't
have clearance for the information that
they were receiving that they were
working on so why did you have them work
with you I don't get that I really don't
and there's like this obvious very
forced dialog moment where they're like
and you thought we were the bad guys
like us audience like us I get it
they're trying to make the good guys in
the movie look worse than the bad guys
so that we then side with the bad guys
that's what you do in a movie where
you're supposed to side with the
criminals in Ocean's eleven you're
supposed to care about Danny ocean and
his team because he's stealing from
somebody who's also kind of an asshole
and so you start to side with the
criminals that's what they did in this
movie by taking Amanda Waller and making
her look actually worse than the Suicide
Squad and it was very obvious something
I was super excited to see in this movie
was Killer Croc I have always liked
Killer Croc this is a very sympathetic
character you feel for him because he
has this condition that makes him this
way and he's always like in the sewers
and he's hiding and he's afraid of thing
and he's just a very cool sympathetic
character I always liked Killer Croc and
in this movie he's just kind of
sidelined to be this guy who sits on the
corner and goes yeah mm-hmm yeah mm-hmm
that's Killer Croc they didn't do
anything with his character he got
nothing he got to throw the bomb at the
end I guess also katana had nothing I
mean she had one shot where she was
crying talking to the soul of her
husband and the sword and that is it
that is the limit of her
characterization she had really nothing
to do in this movie at all see it bugged
me because they have this threat that is
obviously in dire need of some super
people and have
team of people who can throw boomerangs
and can punch people really good and a
couple people like Diablo who can do
some serious shit and he doesn't even
want to do anything for 70 percent of
the movie so I'm like why are these guys
up against this thing it just the plot
did not mesh with the characters they
should have been given a totally
different assignment also let's talk
about flag in this movie played by Joel
Kinnaman who once again is bland as shit
I just I don't believe him as this guy
Tom Hardy was originally supposed to be
this character and that would have been
much better the man that would have been
much better I just don't believe this
guy as rick flagg he just doesn't have
that urgency and really the whole movie
didn't have that sense of urgency it was
just like the beat up things movie like
that's it it was just Harley with a bat
and a mallet and then some people
throwing boomerangs and stuff and the
stuff would disintegrate the best action
scene in the movie is when dead shots
standing on top of a car mowing all
these things down also let's talk about
the fact that the trailer tried to make
it seem like it was the Joker versus
Suicide Squad there's a part in the
trailer where the Joker comes through a
doorway and it cuts to Deadshot going
not good yeah totally different moments
mish-mashed into a trailer to try to
make it seem like one flowing scene it
reminded me the trailer for the Bourne
Legacy where they tried to make it seem
like Edward Norton was going to be
versing Jeremy Renner and it was going
to be like this big scene and there's
nothing like that in the movie it was
just two different scenes completely
mishmash together to make you seem like
a certain type of confrontation was
going to happen that's never in the
movie the Joker was also very sidelined
in this movie I don't really know why he
was in this movie every time he's on
screen it feels like a completely
different film which goes back to that
editing I'm curious to see if we're
going to get another like three hour cut
of this movie where things flow better
because this feels like three different
movies at once one of them is like a
Ghostbusters supernatural thing in the
middle of the city another is a
straight-up action movie with this squad
and then the Joker and his crime ring
and then there's even a fourth movie I
guess with all the flashbacks it's just
this big thing that it's just no and
speaking of the Joker there's that whole
sequence for his
Falls and explodes and we think he's
dead and Harley's all sad but I guess he
didn't die and they never really
explained what happened or show what
happened because he shows up at the end
in a SWAT uniform with the word Joker by
the way right on his splat costume and I
was actually picturing the Joker like
calling a clothing company like ah yeah
cuz yeah but my name on the suit please
that's what I want you to do I really
need the name on the suit can you do
that for me thank you and there is a
mid-credits scene where Bruce Wayne is
talking to Amanda Waller basically
saying look I'm gonna start a Justice
League forget about this Suicide Squad
thing and I didn't know what to think
about that I was like is that are they
telling us to forget about the Suicide
Squad because the Justice League is
happening or is this huh well Justice
League I guess is coming and it looks
good so hopefully it is so those are my
spoiler filled thoughts on Suicide Squad
I think that there is somewhere in this
movie a good movie and it is so
frustrating how much shit is just piled
around it trying to make it a better
movie when they could have just taken
all that shit and just removed it and
just had this squad do something that
made sense that worked for them and just
made a movie focused on them or even
like I said that Joker and Harley idea
with the flashbacks that was more
intriguing to me than them going up
against the beam in the sky that's in
every movie ever now so once again
hopefully Wonder Woman and the Justice
League these movies do look good and I
have a lot of anticipation for them
still those are my spoiler filled
thoughts on Suicide Squad I'm curious to
know what you guys thought of it because
I know a lot of people did enjoy it I
know a lot of people did not enjoy it
it's again another polarizing movie you
guys are the best thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes